but let's turn it back to Maurice in
Zagreb as he has a very special
superstar with Maurice Maurice will make
it a young star as the the Gaspar young
star program is of course all over the
world and Gaspar EV has brought six of
the most talented kids here in Europe to
Croatia to Zagreb to do a training in
with us is young Robert Crangle from
Romania we know a good guy from Romania
our own Christian Carillo of course and
he's 13 years old
the top under 14 year old in his country
right now Robert welcome to the show I'm
Brian very player it's a very big
pleasure to be here and I'm very nervous
oh don't worry about it we just had to
talk about chess you know all about that
first of all what does it feel like to
be here with all these amazing chess
players playing in this place yeah it's
a great feeling guy can't believe my
eyes like he's like whoa
Carson was one meter apart from me it
was like I think it was amazing you are
a fan you said of Magnus Carlsen why do
you like him so much I don't know I like
his attitude I think he's the best from
all the reasons yeah I like him because
he's playing football - football yeah oh
yeah oh there you go so you got chess
and football as well but you're here
also you get to be that close to Carlsen
but you're gonna work personally with
garry kasparov the legend I mean all of
us would just get on our knees and pray
if we had a chance to do that how do you
feel about it I feel amazing I haven't
thought that I heard I would have the
occasion to met one of the best players
in the world but here I am in Zagreb to
meet him absolutely incredible for sure
well knowing that you're gonna work with
all those young
as well are you looking forward to some
of these parties or have you met all of
them that you're going to be working
with no I don't know who I'm going
working with so this is now for you
completely yes what did you feel when
you heard the news like the moment you
heard hey Robert
you're gonna work with garry kasparov
like could you could you believe that
when it when it was said here it was a
great moment my parents told me that
thanked in December when Kasparov came
in Romania at Marriott at the
intelligence in their sniffing or if
share intelligence something like that
big event okay
yeah and I mean that a month I heard the
news and I was so excited like an early
Christmas present and finally we're the
Grantchester is gonna be in Romania
later in November I mean it just gets
better and better for this country how
did you feel about this yeah I'm very
happy that the
Grantchester will be will be played in
Romania it will be very close to me
because I'm leaving Romania Bucharest
I'm sure that they were gonna watch all
the games and yeah I weighed them well
it should be a lot of fun
congratulations and all the good things
that are coming to you great stuff and
go enjoy Magnus and the games thank you
guys Robert crying the crank up he said
I got to work on that pronunciation but
one of the top youngsters getting a
chance to work with the legendary Garry
Kasparov thank you
[Music]